Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
L'empatia corrisponde,
sostanzialmente,
al nostro bisogno di comunicazione
e di condivisione.
Viviamo in un'epoca di crisi economiche,
di catastrofi naturali,
di lacerazione dei rapporti
e delle relazioni sociali,
di violenze commesse
in seguito all'odio e al fanatismo.
E quindi il richiamo dell'empatia
ci serve per aiutare gli altri,
per occuparci - o almeno
non essere indifferenti -
alla miseria e alle privazioni
di vaste popolazioni del nostro pianeta.
Però, per aiutare gli altri
è necessario non considerarli
soltanto delle vittime passive.
Qualche volta noi pensiamo
che abbiano solo bisogno
di un aiuto materiale.
Si tratta invece di sapere
che sono uomini, donne
che hanno una storia,
un progetto di vita, dei desideri.
Ed è proprio qui che dobbiamo chiederci:
ma perché, per amare gli altri,
dobbiamo vederli soffrire?
Ho già parlato di indifferenza:
spesso, pur vedendo un altro che soffre,
voltiamo la testa dall'altra parte.
Ora, l'empatia è proprio la capacità
che ci permette di entrare
direttamente in contatto,
anche semplicemente guardando
una persona in faccia,
cioè vedendo, per esempio,
che ha una smorfia
un po' cupa delle labbra,
oppure ha gli occhi un pochino tristi:
ecco, l'empatia ci mette
in contatto diretto con le persone
a partire proprio dai gesti.
Non ci vogliono, spesso,
nemmeno le parole,
per capire che un'altra persona
ha qualche problema:
anche, certamente,
che ce l'ha con noi, per esempio,
o ha bisogno di qualcosa d'altro.
Si tratta di una capacità -
e questo bisogna saperlo,
ripetercelo molto spesso -
di cui tutti siamo dotati.
Dell'empatia, infatti,
oggi conosciamo molto
a livello scientifico,
conosciamo la sua storia
nell'evoluzione della specie:
è stata fondamentale
per la cooperazione e per l'associazione,
e anche per la cura
dei piccoli e dei deboli.
Sappiamo anche molto
dei circuiti cerebrali
associati all'empatia.
Però non basta pensare
che l'empatia sia un istinto,
o si inneschi con una scarica di neuroni.
Perché se fosse così,
non potremmo spiegarci
come mai la paura dell'altro
è un aspetto fondamentale,
non solo della nostra società
ma anche della nostra vita.
Paura, qualche volta,
persino di innamorarci.
Perché abbiamo paura di essere traditi,
di essere abbandonati.
Oltretutto, poi, pensiamo
a come sia difficile oggi comunicare
tra vecchi e giovani, tra uomini e donne -
anche questa, una storia
purtroppo nefasta,
soprattutto negli ultimi tempi:
tra ricchi e poveri; tra Nord e Sud;
tra gente che abita in città
e gente che abita in campagna.
Il mondo in cui noi viviamo, quindi,
fa dell'empatia
quella che io chiamo una "wake up call".
Cioè un avvertimento,
che può essere anche forte, violento,
a investire le nostre energie nel rischio,
nella difficoltà, molto spesso,
della scoperta dell'altro.
L'empatia deve diventare
per noi una sveglia,
perché proprio in questo modo, io credo,
diventerà un turning point fondamentale
per il futuro di questo mondo,
che attraversa crisi profonde.
E non penso soltanto all'economia,
ovviamente, alla finanza;
ma penso anche all'ambiente.
C'è solo - questo turning point
per cui ognuno di noi
mette qualcosa di sé, incontrando l'altro,
facendo, diciamo affrontando
l'esperienza delle relazioni -
solo in questo modo, forse,
fermeremo una deriva catastrofica.
Scoprire l'altro
è la quintessenza dell'empatia.
Può sembrare una cosa piuttosto semplice:
invece, se pensiamo alla società digitale,
ai mezzi di comunicazione, al web,
ma anche al mondo globalizzato,
scoprire l'altro non è così semplice,
nel senso che proprio
i dispositivi digitali,
ma anche i voli aerei,
che ci permettono velocemente
di andare da un'altra parte del pianeta
ci mettono a contatto con altri distanti,
di cui spesso non conosciamo la lingua,
non conosciamo la cultura,
non sappiamo niente
delle loro credenze o della loro fede.
Proprio perché queste nuove forme
di socialità, in cui tutti siamo immersi,
ci mettono a contatto
con altri senza nome,
spesso gruppi e popolazioni, appunto,
vittime, per esempio,
di catastrofi naturali;
o di queste grandi migrazioni.
D'altra parte, altri che stanno con noi
abitano il mondo con noi.
Sono parti, attori
della nostra stessa scena.
Proprio per questo, noi spesso
ci fermiamo a simpatie immediate,
oppure anche a repulsioni
o avversioni immediate.
Faccio degli esempi che sono noti a tutti:
perché noi ci emozionano
per la foto di un bimbo -
per esempio quella famosa foto,
diventata virale,
del bambino che è tirato fuori
dalle macerie di Aleppo -
e poi noi italiani,
che andiamo benissimo d'accordo
con un immigrato che lavora
in un mercato, oppure al bar,
eppure nel piazzale
della Stazione Centrale
ci irritiamo perché diciamo:
ma guardate tutti questi
presunti rifugiati,
che non fanno niente tutto il giorno!
Questa è veramente
una bella contraddizione:
ma ci dice, soprattutto,
la fatica e la difficoltà di fare i conti
con la differenza dell'altro,
che sia un giovane, che sia un immigrato,
che sia un anziano,
o appunto che sia uno straniero.
La prima lezione dell'empatia,
da questo punto di vista,
sta proprio nel prestare ascolto,
senza buttarci giù e dire:
"Vabbè, io sono egoista
e quindi non mi interesso".
No: dobbiamo prestare ascolto
a queste nostre risposte spontanee,
queste nostre immediate avversioni.
Siamo anche noi -
come si dice volgarmente,
"abbiamo i nostri problemi".
Ma prestare ascolto,
e prenderle sul serio,
vuol dire accettare
che le nostre attrazioni,
le nostre simpatie e le nostre antipatie
possono anche dare vita
a qualcosa di diverso.
E quindi, possano anche portarci
a riconoscere il valore
di quelli che abitano
il mondo insieme a noi,
che come noi hanno delle emozioni,
hanno dei pensieri, hanno dei desideri.
La scienza sta lavorando molto su questo,
e per esempio -
questo secondo me
è un risultato interessante -
ci dice che non esistono
le persone naturalmente empatiche.
Un luogo comune è che le donne
sono più empatiche degli uomini.
Gli esperimenti in neuroscienze
hanno abbastanza relativizzato
questo tipo di luogo comune.
Il che vuole anche dire
che non esistono uomini freddi,
calcolatori ed egoisti,
geneticamente
o naturalmente anti-empatici.
E tutto questo cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che l'empatia è una capacità
sicuramente cablata nel cervello;
ma una capacità che dobbiamo, anche,
scegliere di coltivare.
Oltretutto, poi,
sapendo che è molto delicata
e molto fragile.
Altri studi, altrettanto interessanti
di quelli che ho appena citato,
ci dicono che per esempio è più facile
essere empatici con i nostri familiari,
con chi appartiene al nostro gruppo,
al nostro ambiente,
piuttosto che con quelli
che parlano un'altra lingua,
o di cui conosciamo ben poco.
Così pure si fa più fatica
a essere empatici
quando si è stressati,
oppure quando si è depressi.
Cito questo tipo di conoscenza
proprio per dire
come bisogna essere molto realisti,
ma realisti anche
nei confronti di noi stessi.
Cioè, essere empatici non vuol dire
essere buoni e basta,
quindi non essere cattivi.
Tutti noi viviamo, a seconda appunto
delle circostanze di vita,
delle fasi della vita -
se siamo più giovani, se siamo più adulti,
se abbiamo altro tipo di problemi -
viviamo dei momenti
in cui l'empatia può abbassarsi,
può essere anche
un po' limitata, un po' scarsa;
ma tutto questo non toglie
che l'esperienza empatica
possa essere rinnovata e ripresa.
Con questo cosa voglio dire?
In fondo, la vita
è una grande scuola di empatia.
È vero che noi entriamo
in contatto con gli altri
in maniera estremamente entusiasmante
nell'amore e nell'amicizia,
e siamo coinvolti con le nostre emozioni
ma anche proprio
con la nostra sensibilità,
con le sensazioni.
Eppure, ricordiamoci
che basta conversare
con un amico, o con un'amica,
uscendo da un cinema.
Basta aprire la finestra e guardare fuori,
guardare per esempio
un vecchietto un po' malandato,
che cammina a fatica,
perché le nostre emozioni
e le nostre sensazioni,
quindi questa possibilità di aprirci
alle storie degli altri,
all'esistenza degli altri,
anche solo per pochi secondi,
è una possibilità alla portata di tutti.
In questo senso, dicevo,
la vita è scuola di empatia.
Viaggiare ci insegna a empatizzare;
imparare le lingue straniere,
per capire quelli che parlano
una lingua diversa dalla nostra;
conversare - il piacere, qualche volta
anche la noia della conversazione -
è molto importante,
proprio per vivere e sviluppare
questa formidabile capacità umana
che è piena di potenzialità.
In un mondo globale, in fondo,
noi dobbiamo reimparare ogni giorno
a stare insieme agli altri:
tra uomini e donne,
tra genitori e figli,
tra studenti e insegnanti
e tra colleghi di lavoro.
Ora questo, diciamo riapprendimento -
che contrasta, è vero,
con la velocità, con i problemi
delle nostre vite quotidiane,
è però decisivo per rendere
il mondo più umano.
E per, soprattutto, apprezzare l'umanità
di quelli che abitano la stessa terra
allo stesso modo in cui la abitiamo noi.
Con questo, vorrei lanciare il messaggio
che l'empatia - ripeto: una capacità
di cui tutti e tutte siamo dotati -
è creativa, è generosa.
Soprattutto, ci porta
a guardare in avanti.
E questo è tanto più importante
in un mondo che ha paura,
oggi, del futuro.
[Pensate a] Greta che dice:
voi adulti ci rubate il futuro.
Questa è un'accusa
pesantissima, per noi adulti.
L'empatia aiuta, anche noi adulti,
e non solo i giovani,
a guardare in avanti.
A rischiare, ad accettare la fatica,
anche i conflitti d'interesse,
di valore e di forme di vita
che sicuramente ci sono,
quando entriamo
in relazione con gli altri.
Perché in questo modo noi, in fondo,
arrichiamo la nostra vita
e le nostre esperienze.
E adesso concludo chiedendovi una cosa.
Fate solo un gesto:
voltatevi verso il vostro vicino,
e guardatelo dritto in faccia.
Poi fate un respiro profondo,
e come se vi sentiste liberati da un peso,
sorridete.
(Applausi)